hi everybody my name is Daniel M Berman
and I'm gonna settle yes and this is
minimum viable data products from zero
to data science pipelines so what is a
minimum viable data product well before
we can even dive into that let's start
out with what is a product and at its
core a product is something that brings
value to a customer so when you think of
wrappi you think of being able to
instantly have access to supermarkets
restaurants pharmacies ATMs anything you
need delivered to you that is the value
proposition and if a company doesn't
offer some form of value customers don't
use it and then that company doesn't
have engineers and then those engineers
don't come to PI data Cordova so that is
what a product is but more important
into this talk is what is a data product
and what a data product is is a feature
that personalizes your experience so
taking this to the real world think
about when you go to your favorite pizza
restaurant you walk in the owner knows
you by name they sit you down they don't
even need to take your order they
immediately know your favorite type of
pizza and that's why even though the
quality of the pizza is a little so-so
you still come back because you feel
that you are known there and that we
want to mimic this within our
applications so when you have a search
bar that remembers your order or a
suggestion tab that can compare you to
other users and allow you to expand your
case but safely or even an auto check
out that knows your favorite brand of
ice cream after you have a bad day these
are all situations where we are using
your data to improve your experience
within the application but most
importantly good products and good data
products do not appear out of thin air
many have to start as Minimum Viable
products yeah and when I moved minimum
by L products according to Erika Reyes
the liana start-up alpha there are a
minimum feature set to Express
what a product can be and helps to teams
and entrepreneurs an easy iteration to
incorporate clients our feedback with
constant validation of parallel market
feet every step of the process what out
what a minimum bio-data products are
what they help us to answer questions
like does this product introduce new
information to the customer cares about
is doing doing something enough accuracy
to be battable for them does it worth
the company to do the buying of the
proud of you are developing and
iterating by yourself over your small
team we both Minimum Viable Product and
minimal bio-data product there is a
single factor is consistent for success
and this is the most important part
MVP's is the ability to iterate quickly
and so that's what we want to kind of go
over is the idea of going from zero to a
full data science product a pulled data
science pipeline and so we're gonna be
throwing a lot of technologies at you in
this talk but we're going to do so in a
measured faction in a met in a measured
speed so by the end of this talk you
will understand what all these
technologies are but we promised not to
overwhelm so let's start out at the very
beginning you are a data scientist you
know Python you know math and maybe you
know a little bit about docker and you
want to be able you have a cool idea but
you have no funding for that idea so
where do you start how do you start with
a simple environment that allows you to
play with your data and build a basic
data model well you start with a jupiter
notebook i'm netbooks are great for a
great way to for telling stories and
jupiter novels it is a charity
interpreter for python and if you
install our julia javascript you can use
it as well enables each relative our
experimentation
your data you seen and us I could learn
in PI forever and has a great in
integration with pandas and and
tensorflow
and if you are able to use these great
docker stacks this are rebuild images
docker images containing all your useful
libraries you usually use in data
science like tennis or crowd by spark
environments you have also mined them
out not both environments so you can
start off right away very soothing and
this guy is also great this is the
integrated development environment for
Jupiter notebooks and not only you can
explore novels and edited in real time
with your called life but you can also
create text files with marker markdowns
well navigate using the the file system
browser and even has a terminal so if
you are using like a docker environment
with containers you can explore it
writing your notebooks and it will soon
replace the current Jupiter notebooks
environment you have you have in there
if you are trying to scan the record we
have this sample just starting up the
Jupiter environment with docker compose
wrap and that's it
have it there we have this Kegel the
chaotic tannic example you might be
using if you start in data science we
shut it out we just a random for its
sample when you come low the train and
test example here in live you can see
the shape how many features you have in
that that in the data set train it
evaluate how well this is working your
your classifier and add more estimators
for example just sir contested again
train
evaluate the disciplic ater and then see
how it works and now the score is
slightly higher so if you are at a
company where you've all decided that
Jupiter notebooks want to be you want to
paterno books to be as first-class
citizen and you want an easy way to
distribute your Jupiter notebooks
Jupiter actually has a lot of pretty
awesome features within their ecosystem
that make it easy to distribute and also
have access to distributed libraries
from within your notebooks so for
example Jupiter hub is one of the
community supported options where it
allows for users have remote running of
Jupiter notebooks so you can have
multi-tenancy on a single instance it
all it has a native runtimes for both
docker and for kubernetes and so this is
one way to ensure that a large number of
data scientists can have access to
Jupiter very scalable for actually
scaling out jobs within your Jupiter
notebook there's a jupiter enterprise
gateway which allows jupiter to run
natively on schedulers like yarn and
kubernetes
and has integrations with SPARC tasks
and other parallel libraries so you can
start out by using some of these
libraries within your notebook just
locally and then scale out to using a
full spark cluster and if you are
interested in being able to share some
of your work with the community binder
hub is a pretty cool integration where
you can get upload your jupiter
notebooks and then share them so this is
especially great for academic use cases
where you want to be able to show the
rest of the community your notebooks oh
papermill this is a reason we are here
actually this is an old library where
you come paradise not vote through cell
tagging execute notebooks using the
python api and using the CLI and store
them in s3 i sure and I will show you
example how we do it using this cell
metadata select the cell where we are
setting a was a be equal
speak we add a metadata there and now
paper mill is able to identify that
their cell needs to be overridden here's
example and now using the iPhone API
will provide an input in C when we read
it an output notebook path and some
parameters we are saying the a is equal
to Mb is called bar now they're
executing a little bit wait a second two
seconds and the output is just Jupiter
not boots as well but now we have
replaced the parameters before so now a
equals two and the physical bar and this
is what he's doing paper mill kind since
is replacing is creating that cell and
adding an injected parameter tag yeah to
them and imagine this is just text
imagine plots
imagine datasets imagine outputs and
just replacing one cell and you are
creating multiple reports from just one
to turn a book and you are in example
the Kaggle example we are setting this
first cell with numerous estimators and
the route path so you can be placing
them for an outside so this is where
things start to get a little bit cool
because all of this has everything
you've been doing so far has just been
on your laptop's so you now have the
ability with no buy-in from anyone else
in your company to just create a Jupiter
notebook and parameterize it but once
you parameterize it how do you
productionize it how do you test across
a series of different parameters how do
you make sure that you are building the
best model you can and this is actually
where Apache airflow can come in and be
extremely useful
so Apache airflow is an open source
workflow scheduler where users can write
out their directed acyclic graphs or
DAGs as Python code and air flow
interprets it live and you can build
some pretty complex workflows with
very little actual configuration it's
easy the schedule it scales pretty
nicely and it offers a lot of tool for
monitoring so when you go to your base
directory you have access to all of your
graphs you can see which runs at Pass
which ones have failed you can see
historical runs and you can even see if
you look on the right there this is what
a compiled dag looks like so from a
simple Python file you're able to
actually create some pretty complex
shapes so this is an example dag where
each task in the dag is defined as an
operator so you create a Python class
and then you can use a set up stream
function to set the dependencies the way
that airplay works is none no task will
run until all of its dependencies have
been met but we're here for data science
so let's talk about a few data science
use cases and how air flow can actually
help with those probably one of my
favorite ones would be hyper parameter
tuning and canary testing and so hyper
parameter tuning is let's say you have
your notebook set you have your model
but you don't know what the optimal set
of parameters is that's what hyper
parameter tuning is is figuring out what
are the best things what's the best loss
rate what's the best tolerance what are
the best parameters that will make for
the most accurate model and so the
simplest form of hyper parameter tuning
is called grid search it's essentially a
nested for loop so you nested you would
nested for loop for every for every
parameter you're tuning against and it
will run all possibilities this is where
pythonic dad creation can really shine
and so here we have an example of an
airflow pipeline that's very simple it's
just three tasks running one after
another and we want to do hyper
parameter tuning on this so we go back
to our code example and let's say we add
we want to tune on the loss rate so
first let's separate separate out these
three tasks just so that it's easier to
check out and when you're doing this
click the refresh button bear don't
click the one on your browser because
that actually pulls the new information
from the database and now we want to be
a
to check out a whole series of potential
loss rates so we create a for
comprehension for I in range let's say 2
to 20 in steps of 2 so that's basically
in three lines of Python code we're able
to scale this out so then we do or loss
rate and loss rates and now we can scale
out to 10 10 different versions a
hundred or even a thousand different
hyper parameters with pretty minimal
Python code changes but we also want to
remember that this was a pipeline so we
want each of these steps to be one after
the other so we can go back to our code
and basically keep track of all of the
last steps so for previous tasks in
previous stuff
so
yes let me increase the size of that
so for what we do is that for each of
the previous steps we essentially will
add a dependency to each of those middle
steps and then append every notebook
that we're running clear there's
previous steps and if we by the way this
will all be in the github repo so your
this will all be accessible after the
talk but now we are back to having a
full pipeline but with a scalable hyper
parameter tuning at every step along the
way however grid search is not the most
efficient because you're gonna end up
doing a lot of steps after you've
already found your best solution so we
want to figure out ways to avoid
unnecessary processing and we can do
that through by having a maximum fit so
oftentimes in models you don't want to
over fit so you might set some threshold
and say at 97% accuracy this model is
good enough so you can essentially if
you have some form of a source of truth
be that source of truth as 3po stress or
Redis you can then say once you've hit
that source of once you hit that optimal
amount you can use a what's called a
short-circuit operator and the
short-circuit operator will take in the
previous information and say okay I
don't need to finish any of these
further steps we've found our correct
model another example would be for
canary testing so canary testing is
let's say you're building a new model
every day and you want to make sure that
a that new model is better than the
previous models we've built otherwise
there's no point in changing the models
and B that you want to be able to do
some error detection so if a model goes
from 80% accuracy to 95% accuracy maybe
some things a little bit wrong with how
you've been training it and so the way
you can do that is through what's called
a branch operator so as you can see here
we have a compare results function where
we take all our connections a zoom in on
that
so we have a compare results function
where we take all the old models and we
essentially say if the new model if any
of the old models is better than the new
model deploy the alert of a failure
otherwise deploy the new model
so if we go back to air flow we can see
here that we can run the canary test and
if we go to the actual dag you'll see
that it actually runs all the new models
and then it has a what's called a
branching operator and based on the
facts the first time the new model is
the best model therefore when compare
results runs it skips the failure mode
and goes directly to the model
deployments but if we go back and we
change the minimum value of the old
models five so now they're higher than
the new model we can rerun this dag and
you'll see that it goes to the failure
mode
so unwrapping we take advantage of this
and the extended extension nature of
airflow and we we write this product
called rapid flow from here from Cordova
to the entire continent and we write
custom plugins plus with the moon
astronomer have been in the deployment
we can easily get these use cases that
are common for us like SQL plus panda
adding some programmatic pipelines to
generate Dax and calling local images
for training and off-site prediction
right very actually for from air flow so
we don't have to worry about having like
really expensive and complex libraries
in air flow but we are calling the core
images for it and the program the
programmatics pipelines are this kind of
guys we have the long liner
there are like four loops of calling SQL
files an array of of SQL files and you
can do things like this we have one
pipeline and we had tens of of lines and
then a for loop and now we are
processing the entire continent just
with the same amount of lines and that's
programmatic that is and with this we
also extend in an air flow operator
called community sport operator that
triggers and docker image into
kubernetes and we send it just adding
more environment variables resources how
much CPU memory you need and secrets
credentials to secret and and that's it
and you are calling your doctor images
step from there so now you have a
working we have a working Jupiter Nova
we've used paper mill to parameterize it
and we're able to use air flow to scale
it but you're starting to run into a
problem where it's one thing to run one
Jupiter notebook in parallel like is
wanting to run one Jupiter notebook on
your laptop and I know
10 Jupiter notebooks and another thing
completely to run a hundred or a
thousand Jupiter notebooks in parallel
on a single laptop so this is the point
where you start might start actually
meeting some infrastructure but
hopefully at this point you've built a
good enough model and built enough of an
MVP to get some form of buy-in from your
company so let's say now you have some
time and you have some infrastructure
and you want to be able to scale out
Apache airflow to run hundreds or
thousands of tasks in parallel well
there's two main options for scaling in
Apache airflow there's the kubernetes
executor and the celery executor what
the kubernetes executor does is one of
the nice things about it is that you
only need kubernetes you don't need any
extra infrastructure you don't need to
manage celery or anything else and it
has what's called dynamic allocation
where essentially air flow is able to
speak to Cooper Nettie's and dynamically
launch pods one pod per every task
you're running and in times when you
have a lot of load it will expand out
that cluster and then once everything is
completed it shrinks back down to a
single pod so it's not wasting your AWS
bill or electricity and it also has a
pretty cool fault tolerance story where
you can let's say you have TAS that
absolutely need to run the and scheduler
dies we're actually able to use both
post stress and the kubernetes api to
completely recreate state so that we're
ensured that no tasks ever runs twice
and no tasks ever gets lost however
there still are good use cases for when
you want to use the celery executors so
let's say you're doing something online
and you want to make sure that you have
very fast SL A's you might not want to
wait for a pod to launch every time
you're running a task therefore you can
have certain benefits for very
short-term SL A's and you could have a
multi-tenancy per worker when you have
the static workers of the celery
executors but there's one other feature
of the kubernetes executor that I think
would be particularly valuable in the
data science use case and that is the
ability to have an executor config
because we're launching a new pod every
time you're launching a new task the
kubernetes
executor allows you to determine
specific features of the pot based on
just what's in the operator so for
example if you're having one task that
runs a Jupiter notebook and another that
just sends a spark request you're gonna
have very different needs for how much
memory and how much CPU you're gonna
want per pod you're also if you're
dealing with personal information might
want to have service accounts such that
one pod only has access to GCP and one
pod only had access to AWS and if you're
doing things with tensorflow you can
even go so far as to set a node affinity
to make sure that that task runs in the
GPU enabled node and when it comes to
deploying apache airflow on kubernetes
and celery there are a few main options
you can of course these are open source
all open source technologies you can run
them yourself but I do also want to
mention that there's a company called
astronomer Daioh which essentially
offers airflow as a service now full
disclosure this is the company I work
for I work for it but it's a it's a
pretty cool product where essentially
you have a UI you can press a button and
you can launch either kubernetes
executor or celery executor and it also
offers some pretty great monitoring and
support but another reason why I'm
mentioning right now is there's a pretty
cool local development story with
astronomer that you don't even need to
sign up for anything for you just need
to download this like the CLI so if you
run this curl command and you download
the astronomer CLI you can essentially
just create an empty directory run Astro
Devon it and it will create an entire
airflow environment for you so this
environment has a docker file it has a
dag folder it has all your packages and
requirements and you can modify all of
this as much as you like and so then
once your and we even offer an example
dad just to show you what the dads would
look like and so then once you're at the
point where you feel that your DAGs are
ready you can pretty easily start an
airflow
server on your local docker where if you
just run Astro dev start it will pull
any necessary layers it will then add on
any layers that you personally put on so
any package dependencies and special
configurations we actually have a docker
image in the repository which will show
at the end of the presentation which has
Jupiter and all the jupiter dependencies
so you can see what running Jupiter and
airflow looks like and then it creates
an entire airflow instance so which is
gonna wait for the network to be created
starts Postgres starts scheduler starts
the webserver and then you can go to
your local host 8080 and you will have a
running Apache airplay server and what's
really nice about this is because the
webs because it's attached to a local
volume you'll be able to essentially
live in your IDE modify the Python files
and then go back and see those changes
in your Dax so you can inspect the shape
you can run them with like a local small
amount of data to run locally and you
can test it out so once you have that
local instance once again test it with
the local amount of data and a bit as
far as a big trick or avoiding any
issues with an airflow is try to keep
any complex logic in the actual task so
for example if you have a lot of extra
dependencies for a specific task
consider the kubernetes pod operator so
you can launch any arbitrary docker
image in kubernetes and airflow will
monitor or if you're doing a lot of work
with SPARC make sure that you're using a
spark operator so you can test that
spark job independently of airflow and
only use it as an Orchestrator finally
for deploying airflow once you've done
everything locally and you feel that
your Python files are ready to be sent
out there are a few main options within
kubernetes to allow for deploying Apache
or deploying - to airflow there's the
option of bay
into baking it into the docker image of
having a shared NFS or persistent volume
or using gets sync so that your dad
if you push to get they will be pushed
in to your airflow instances we would
personally recommend that you use baking
it into your docker image unless you
have a multi-tenant airflow cluster so
in terms of simplicity in terms of being
able to easily revert back old changes
having it in your docker image is
easiest but if you're running one large
airflow or your entire company then it
can get pretty painful at every time one
of your engineers makes a change it has
to relaunch the scheduler at which point
you should consider something like NFS
and this is an example of what it would
look like to deploy to astronomers so
first you just do an astro off login you
get you get a URL you go in and you get
a get a key an OAuth key which I will
not be showing the whole thing because I
don't people logging in as me and then
once you've logged in all you have to do
is in that same folder do a store deploy
and pick the cluster you want and it
will take that local image that you've
been running on your laptop and it will
push it to a kubernetes cluster either
using the kubernetes executor or the
celery executor where you can launch a
thousand notebooks at scale and get your
model done at a production level
so then once it's been pushed you can
essentially go back to the astronomer
you I open Apache airflow give it about
30 seconds for the web server to start
and then once it started you can run it
like any other airflow instance
so TLDR quick overview you start out
with a working you start out with a very
simple model in a jupiter notebook you
parameterize it using paper mill you can
tune it test it compare it and
productionize it using airflow and then
you can run it at production scale using
kubernetes or celery and every step
along the way you will have a working
model and every step along the way
you're just adding a small amount more
of infrastructure and by the time you
actually need a kubernetes cluster or
celery workers you should hopefully have
a working data product that you can get
buy-in from management get feedback from
customers and be assured that you are
building something that people that will
bring joy and any questions yes
yeah so the question is is it possible
to use any other search algorithms
besides grid search and the answer is
anything you can write in Python so
what's really great about air flow is
you can so as a Gonzalo had mentioned
rappy builds their own operators from
scratch and you can basically any
configuration you can figure out for
yourself like you can do stochastic
descent you can yeah anything you can
think of a piper any marketer said
whenever Linda said any poniard I mean
fine thank you so much for shared
information
so I actually two questions so first is
how do you run spark jobs on air flow
because and second question is how do
you scale so yeah so as far as running
spark and air flow the answer is don't
but there's a there's a spark job
operator which allows you to submit
spark jobs to yarn or if you guys seen
it there's actually a native spark on
kubernetes now where you can just
download a custom resource and now you
have a scalable Apache spark on your
kubernetes cluster so the airflow spark
spark operator you can just give a KS
URL and it will launch a kubernetes
cluster in your spark in your it'll
launch a spark cluster in your
kubernetes cluster for the second
question as far as scaling Apache
airflow so the two options are the
kubernetes executor and the celery
executor with the celery executor you
have to pre pre provision like static
workers so you decide how many airflow
workers you want and with the kubernetes
executor you just give it a cute config
and it just Auto scales as many
tasks as you want and then shrinks back
down afterwards okay so if I understand
correctly so it means Adler's deployed
in kubernetes
[Music]